[Music]
you're watching the daily climate show
it seems britain's climate reputation is
at stake as a public inquiry into plans
for the uk's first deep coal mine in 30
years opens
british airways reveals its plans for
the future of flying but are measures
like sustainable fuel credits enough to
sufficiently reduce emissions
and our city is ready for the effects of
climate change in today's daily debate
we ask how where we live will need to
change as extreme weather events become
more common
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with the
solutions and we're starting today at
our data dashboard because it shows the
impact that we're having on our planet
now this number here is how much the
world has warmed since the industrial
revolution and as you can see it's
rising fast now that's because we keep
burning things which produces greenhouse
gases like carbon dioxide in the process
so if we're going to limit global
warming and avoid the worst impacts of
the climate crisis burning things like
coal is going to have to stop
but despite having a target of reaching
net zero emissions by 2050 the uk
government is facing criticism for not
stepping in to stop plans for a new coal
mine in cumbria now today an inquiry
into that application opened
so let's take a look at the process so
far well four years ago west cumbria
mining company applied for permission
for a new deep coal mine near whitehaven
now they say that the project will
create more than 500 well-paid jobs at
the mine and a further 1 000 in the
supply chain
between 2019 and 2020 local authorities
approved the plans on three separate
occasions due to changes made to the
initial application although cumbria
county council subsequently withdrew its
support for the mine
then in december 2020 the climate change
committee which advises the government
released a report saying the uk must
move away from using coal and steel
production within the next few years if
the country intends to meet its legal
target of reaching net zero emissions by
2050.
initially the government defended the
decision to allow the coal mine
describing it as a local issue but then
in march the community secretary robert
generic decided to review the
application and that in turn led to the
public inquiry which opened today
well our climate correspondent hannah
thomas peter joins me now so hannah if
this mind does get approval does that
risk compromising the government's
climate credentials
well potentially i've heard from a very
senior person who advises the government
on climate change matters who described
the potential approval of a coal mining
cumbria as just the latest in a series
of pr blunders there was a real sort of
gnashing of teeth about how have we
found ourselves with all of the
legitimate work that the british
government is doing
to advance the cause of tackling the
climate crisis host of cop 26 climate
change summit
in glasgow later this year how can the
government find itself in a place
where it what is meeting the headlines
what is going to the top of the agenda
is the extraction of fossil fuels in uk
territory not just the cumbrian coal
mine but of course the ongoing approval
of new new licenses to drill for oil
in the north sea now look there are
several there are a whole range of of
concerns the first one is of course a
practical one um campaigners and indeed
scientists and advisers say that if the
cumbrian coal mine was to be
approved it would certainly make it
harder for the uk to meet its net zero
obligations and it certainly will not
help the rest of the world
to do the same this is what the chairman
of the climate change committee lord
david had to say
this is holy contrary
both to the advice we have given and to
the fundamental issue
of the
budgets to which parliament has signed
up and which are now law so this is
contrary in our view to the law
now the government's position is well
this is a local planning matter we can't
really get involved that's not
appropriate
that's the position they're trying to
defend this is what uh the prime
minister spokesperson on cop 26 electric
allegra stratton had to say earlier
today
it isn't appropriate for me to comment
on the cumbria coal mine uh it's now
with the planning inspector and i and i
can't comment either way but what i can
say is that the uk has made brilliant
progress in eliminating or getting very
close to eliminating coal from its power
generation we will be removing coal from
our power generation in 2024 that is a
year earlier than we we had planned so
we've brought that forward
now yes the government has to balance
the very real needs of local communities
who are interested of course in those
short-term jobs but the much broader
concern is that the uk is risking its
moral authority on climate change at the
very moment where it needs to be
marshaling the momentum of the
international community and asking
people not to approve more fossil fuel
product projects while simultaneously on
its own soil in its own waters
considering doing exactly that
hannah thanks very much
and a reminder that you can read more
about this and all the other climate
stories of the day on our website just
head to sky news dot com slash climate
in today's other climate news europe had
its warmest summer on record this year
the latest milestone in a trend of
rising temperatures the average surface
air temperature in june and august was
close to one degree celsius above the
1991-2020 average the previous warmest
summers in 2010 and 2018 were 0.1
degrees cooler
the environment agency is allowing waste
water treatment works to release
untreated sewage if they're experiencing
supply chain disruption to their
chemicals usually a permit is required
which is subject to strict compliance
rules a government spokesperson said
that the action is strictly time limited
and there are robust conditions in place
to mitigate risks to the environment
the world's three main christian leaders
have issued an unprecedented joint
appeal to members of their churches to
listen to the cry of the earth
pope francis archbishop justin welby and
ecumenical patriarch bartholomew
released a joint statement urging
everyone to play their part in
protecting the planet together they
represent more than 1.6 billion
christians around the world
some warm-blooded animals are having to
shape-shift to adapt to the warming
climate that's according to researchers
who reported animals are getting larger
beaks legs and ears to better regulate
their body temperatures the report says
this is particularly common in birds but
it's not clear whether all animals are
capable of adapting to increasing global
temperatures
and football clubs across the uk have
launched the campaign to fight climate
change cup 26
kicks off today with fans able to score
goals online by making climate conscious
decisions such as eating plant-based
meals or cycling or walking to work and
school
premier league teams will be playing
in a tournament in the run-up to the
climate summit cop 26 with the ultimate
goal being to raise awareness of climate
change
now u.s president joe biden is visiting
communities that were hit by flooding
and tornadoes last week
at least 50 people were killed in six
states after record rainfall in the wake
of hurricane ida the president has
proposed a trillion dollar
infrastructure bill to modernize roads
bridges sewers and drainage systems in
an effort to protect people from extreme
weather events which are expected to
become more frequent due to climate
change
for decades
scientists have warned of extreme
weather
would be more extreme and climate change
was here and we're living through it now
we don't have any more time
and we'll be discussing how cities need
to adapt to deal with the effects of
climate change later in the programme
i'm going to be joined by podcast host
mariam pascha and white house climate
advisor jerome foster for today's daily
climate show debate
now flying is responsible for around two
and a half percent of global carbon
dioxide emissions and the aviation
sector is one of the fastest growing
sources of greenhouse gases so finding
solutions to reduce the climate impact
of how we travel is a key focus for the
industry
well today british airways announced a
new sustainability program including
plans to use more sustainable fuel
our business correspondent paul kelso
was at that launch
british airways along with every other
airline has got a problem how do you
sustain an industry entirely reliant on
burning fossil fuels that are
incompatible with global climate targets
well today we started to get part of the
answer we've got a slogan be a better
world and a one-off livery on this
airbus here and some commitments long on
ambition if a little short on detail ba
will rely on further carbon offsetting
developing sustainable aviation fuel as
well as hydrogen flight and carbon
capture technology to hit a target of
net zero by 2050 now even if they're
successful they'll still be emitting
around 40 percent of today's co2 levels
despite this chief executive sean doyle
told me there is a sustainable future
for his airline and for mass passenger
flight in general in a net zero world
the airline industry is very aware of
the challenges it faces in relation to
sustainability but we do have solutions
we've got new investment in technologies
we've got new forms of fuel new forms of
propulsion and we're also investing
significantly in carbon offsetting but
you know travel is a hugely important
part of the way we live our lives it's
very important to the global economy
it's very important to tourism we're a
global community we are an industry that
will need longer to find a sustainable
pathway but we will find one now many of
the technologies british airways is
relying on are unproven on a mass scale
and the challenge of hitting net zero
has been piled on top of the problems of
the pandemic entire fleets grounded
thousands of jobs lost and business
models destroyed and it would have
escaped no one at ba or elsewhere that
their best ever performance in climate
terms has come in the last year when
they've barely flown
and finally lewis pugh the un patron of
the oceans has completed a 7.8 kilometer
swim in greenland's illusat icefjord he
tackled waters clogged with pieces of
ice to highlight the melting of the
greenland ice sheet louis pew has called
for 30 percent of the world's oceans to
be protected by 2030 completing swims in
the arctic antarctic and the english
channel
do stay with us coming up after the
break i'm going to be joined by the host
of the climate curious podcast marion
pasha and the white house climate
advisor jerome foster who is standing by
right now ready and waiting we're going
to be discussing if cities are ready for
the effects of climate change after last
week's devastating floods in the united
states
plus will we all need to stop flying to
save the planet that's all coming up
next
[Music]
i think a lot of the time people get
worried that i'm taking the mick and i'm
poking fun but actually i see it the
other way when i was going through my
own anorexia it was kind of isolating
that people stopped laughing with me
they stopped playing pranks they stopped
mucking about and actually humor has a
brilliant way of bringing people
together it's not always about drawing
people apart so i think that can be used
to build people's confidence their
communication and that connection with
other people because we always see that
people tend to get quite lonely when
they have mental health problems
especially eating disorders so actually
using this it can help combat that but
also provide a platform for them to
quite literally stand up for themselves
there's always a danger of offending
people and i think it's really good
point and that's something that i look
at in the course there's a couple of
things you've got to think of when
you're uh
you know writing a joke firstly it's
what's your relationship to that topic
secondly are you punching up or punching
down so are you critiquing people in
power or are you bullying those who have
less power below you and also what is
your ownership of that topic so for
example if i talked about being a
canadian single mother you think well
what zeno and quite rightly i know
nothing whereas if catherine ryan does
then that comes from a place of
knowledge and experience so that's
something that we do cover in the course
it's six weeks an hour per week plus
homework in between and we have just
been given a wonderful grant by the
british academy to do this throughout
the united kingdom so we're looking for
anyone who's over 18 who has history of
an eating disorder and all types of
eating disorder and whether that's
diagnosed or undiagnosed and all you
need is uh wifi and it's all done
interactively via zoom and it uses peer
support so you get to know people and
we've done a couple of tests and in the
tests uh people have set up whatsapp
groups they've ended up going and
meeting other people a couple have even
gone on to do a couple of five-minute
spots so it's one hour per week over six
weeks to teach you comedy as a method of
dealing with whatever life throws at you
but in a specific instance especially
for people with eating disorders
[Applause]
southeast asia correspondent in bangkok
[Music]
it's estimated that around 70 of our
coastlines are experiencing increased
erosion
[Music]
we start with a steel structure that we
put into the sea floor we then pass a
very small electrical current between
what we call an anode and the cathode
the structure itself is the cathode
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
did you know if more of us walked roll
bikes and scoots to school we would make
a big difference to the evolution around
our school yeah like us
wednesday will be another fine day for
many parts but heavy thundery showers
spreading into the southwest will affect
devon cornwall parts of wales parts of
ireland too
through the course of the day those will
push a little further north and east
but northeastern parts of the country
should have another fine day again with
very high temperatures for the time of
year
in terms of air pollution though we're
looking at
low levels right across the country but
some moderate pockets across parts of
england and wales and some of those
creeping their way up into parts of
scotland too
the air quality report sponsored by
philips air purifiers
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news now we're
getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day now and
challenging the solutions to them too
with the host of the climate curious
podcast marion pascha and jerome foster
an activist and climate advisor to
president joe biden so good evening to
both of you really good to see you
though thanks for joining us
so we're starting today by looking at
the impacts of climate change on our
cities now the past few weeks have
demonstrated that our planet is in
crisis with extreme weather events
affecting countries around the world now
last week storm ida caused devastation
in parts of the united states including
flash flooding in new york now jerome
that's where you are now and i
understand that new york subway flooded
three times this summer i mean that's
evidence that america's just not
equipped to deal with extreme weather
events is it so you're a white house
advisor what are you telling president
biden to do about
it absolutely this is a a clear example
of how america doesn't have enough
investment in infrastructure to protect
us from the climate crisis and the
short-term answer to make sure that we
are
are not long-term impacted by hurricane
irma is to get immediate assistance to
those that are impacted the long-term
answer is to create a civilian climate
corps in america to employ people that
will go door to door and make sure
people have access to climate justice
resources and make sure that they're
able to be rescued and employed after
this so there's so many things we
need to do but not enough is being done
right now and what about the uk mariam
i'm actually going to take a look at
something that the climate change
committee said in a report
this year their advisors to the
government of course they have said the
uk doesn't yet have a vision for
successful adaptation to climate change
so merriman looks like we're not
terribly well prepared here either what
do you think
absolutely i mean in that report they
looked at 34 priority areas i believe
and we haven't made significant progress
on any of them and so i think that
adaptation is not something that you
know people who are not immersed in the
climate conversation every day maybe
have thought about but it is something
that our governments have known we need
to do and action has been has been short
you know has been slow and now might be
too late for some people well yes and
jerome why do you think this is i've
noticed there have been calls this week
to make sure that adaptation that is
things like building flood defenses and
and adapting to a changing climate
should have equal priority at cop26 at
the u.n climate summit um at the moment
there's been a lot of talk about getting
emissions down but do you think that
that's come at the expense of a focus on
adaptation
well i think that the conversation
should be both and it should be one
focusing on future
emissions but also making sure that
we're holding them accountable by seeing
real investment year over year we need
to make sure that every every year we're
seeing actual tangible change and not
pretty words that often fall empty in
communities like how we're seeing in
new york city right now are reeling from
because of the empty promises that
happen in the 2010s
so transparency and holding people to
account mariam also is there an issue of
money here there's only a finite amount
finite amount of money and governments
around the world have spent billions
trying to meet against again mitigate
against covid and is there a risk if you
spend loads of money on adaptation it
takes money away from some of those
future technologies ways of of trying to
get emissions down
i mean i agree with jeremy this is a
both and you're not going to be able to
solve this problem if you only look at
adaptation or you only look at reduction
in emissions and there are some
solutions that amazingly will help us do
both so i think there's some real space
here to be you know innovative and to
think about things like you know
insulating our homes help us protect us
against extreme weather but it also
helps reduce our energy consumption and
these things can be really effective
and jerome i'm just really interested to
think
to hear what you think about public
opinion in the states they've been it's
been a terrible summer for america in
terms of heat waves wildfires floods do
you think that's changing people's minds
on climate change
um well even though i am a white house
advisor i was a climate activist
beforehand i climate strike for over 100
weeks in front of the white house and i
understand that right now the awareness
is not there
the american media is is sadly not like
sky news where you guys break down the
climate crisis our news is very much
just talking about the hurricane but not
talking about the underlying issue that
is the climate crisis so i think that
even though we have seen a rise in so
much natural disasters from california
to florida to louisiana and now new york
city people are not tying them together
and understanding a broader system of
climate change that is continuing to
stabilize our communities okay we're
going to move on to our next subject now
because as we heard earlier in the show
british airways has announced a new
sustainability program but our plans for
things like carbon offsetting and
sustainable aviation fuel enough to help
address the climate impact of flying and
mariam first of all i'm just going to
take our viewers over to show them how
much aviation contributes to global
warming around 2.5
of global carbon dioxide emissions from
aviation it doesn't sound like very much
but mile for mile flying's the most
damaging way to travel as far as the
climate is concerned isn't it so should
we just stop
i mean we i think the first thing to say
is that obviously it does sound like a
small number but aviation is only going
to grow so it's obviously something that
we need to pay attention to but i i
definitely don't agree with that we
should stop flying because i really
believe that actually one of the most
important things is that we need to have
empathy across borders and the only way
we can do that is to go and meet and
travel and be immersed in other cultures
other meet other people and so this idea
that we should have an isolationist
solution just doesn't ring true for me
but i do think that you know we need to
invest in these technology solutions
that really aren't quite there yet and i
think you saw that today with the
announcement from ba
what do you what do you make about
technological solutions can we put our
faith in them jerome can that can that
help us out of this conundrum
hmm um well technological solutions have
to first be able to reach market
properly um because right now we're just
seeing that
aviation companies are saying that oh
they're going to make small emissions
reductions by a certain date but right
now it's incredibly expensive and it
isn't
massively available so right now what
we've seen that's already available is
electric planes they've already seen
that in in some parts of
maine and in canada and some parts of
the united states and if we want to see
massive almost zero emissions from the
get-go then we need electric planes to
to be implemented
and mariam if if it is agreed that we
should fly less there are certainly
people calling for that should
governments get involved in kind of
disincentives if you like should they be
taxing the people that fly the most for
example
i mean i do think looking at a carbon
tax so that we know the true cost of
what we're doing is really important but
you know i don't think that um limiting
and blaming a family who's worked all
year to be able to take a small holiday
with their kids is really how we're
going to solve the climate problem i
think we're looking here at big societal
shifts and aviation has a lot of
thinking to do because it is going to be
one of the hardest ones to
to move but i think it's really about
being thoughtful when you fly okay well
murray and pasha we're out of time
thanks to you and thanks to jerome
foster too joining us there from new
york thanks very much indeed
well that's everything from us for today
on the show tomorrow joining me to
discuss the burning climate issues of
the day will be sepi golzari monroe from
the climate intelligence unit and
extinction rebellion activist chidi oti
obihara
do stay tuned now coming up next on sky
news tonight boris johnson breaks two
manifesto pledges with a tax rise to pay
for social care and the suspension of
the pension triple lock more on that in
a moment but from me thanks for watching
see you next time
[Music]
you